hey leute hier ist wieder eure mal ich
hab neues tattoo adidas schon gesehen
ist gerade ein bisschen trocken wenn ich
heute in der sonne war ich auf meiner
hautfarbe ich bin ein bisschen braun
geworden
schick ich geh da kann man durch die
schulter zeigen wenn man so braun ist wo
bisher hängt in mir das ganze zeit schon
raus kritisch ich bin gerade dabei
viermal war eine videos zu drehen und zu
überlegen und ich sage nur das
sommerloch kommt wieder
ihr habt richtig gehört das auch noch
kommt wieder und vielleicht ein bisschen
renovierter aber an sich das gleiche
frische statur
ach das gab es bei aldi
da ich aber keine lust habt dass die
leute hier ständig auf videos warten
müssen obwohl ich ja die ganze zeit
videos produziere und drehe und alles
mögliche habe ich wieder eins
rausgepickt aus meiner sendung was ich
für diesen kanal auch super passend
finde ich sag nur kalorienbomben
milchshakes lecker manche von euch
werden diese magic vielleicht erkennen
aus casey netz blogs oder allgemeinen
instagram weil wir halt megacool zurzeit
sind und ich finde sie auch mega cool
und keine sorge diese kommt noch ein
video was nur exklusiv für mal wanne
gemacht wurde versprochen
wir machen heute richtig leckeren
einschätzung nicht diese normalen die
welt schon kennt sondern große flüchtige
bunte ich war schon fleißig unterwegs
und habe diabetes und karies geholt in
allen möglichen farben und ausführungen
marshmallow prem milch eiscreme
natürlich sahne und jetzt geht's los
zuerst möchte ich den rand zum glas
dekorieren und das mache ich mit
neuschnee oder wird super ich merke
stufen liebe mache vorbereitet geht es
so bunte genie
die heiligen wolgast ist das nicht cool
jelly beans drauf sondern auch minimal
schneller und das ist nur der rand
sollte das bis nur der hand und sondern
das fertig als nächstes nämlich so rp ob
damit die gericht jetzt das glas innere
denn wenn wir die milch shake masse da
rein machen dann sieht dass schönberg
aus jetzt mit ice cream und machen es in
den witzeleien benötigt er dazu packen
wir noch ein bisschen milch denn sonst
wäre es ja kein milchshake deckel drauf
und der mann schon jetzt haben wir
unseren milchshake masse jetzt wird ganz
kompliziert denn jetzt kommt die
hauptdepot dafür habe ich von so von zum
bunten spies klein abgebrochen so ein
stück
ich muss müssen was ab trinkens zu
folgen
machen wir die sahne obendrauf jetzt
nehmen wir so kleine regenbögen war okay
konzentration jetzt kommt also kleine
nennt man die infos kommen dann noch ein
und jetzt noch unser highlight des tages
ein strohhalm der kommt nämlich rein und
da drüber
zum und ob noch ein paar sprenkel und so
cool
preiset den schönsten magic damit ich
meine so etwas schönes gemacht
ich weiß ich sag das immer aber das ist
wirklich das schönste was ich jemals
gemacht habe
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
schießt